all right as we continue and as we
reported in our opening monologue
tonight the house Intel committee chair
that would be Devin Nunez he has sent a
letter tonight to attorney general
sessions that says the FISA surveillance
application for Carter page a campaign
associate in the Trump administration
for the Trump campaign appears to be a
clear violation of FBI rules for
submitting evidence to the FISA Court
and may also violate criminal statutes
mark Levine's legal foundation the
landmark legal foundation has also filed
a motion they are asking the FISA Court
to do something about the suspected
abuses allegedly committed by the FBI
and the DOJ he's also the host our new
colleague we're proud to have them and
that is life Liberty Levin we want to
call it the great one he's also the host
of Levin TV CR TV
Mark Levin this Nunez memo that I have
here that the FBI could have committed
crimes and that they broke protocol
don't we already know when you don't
tell a FISA judge in your initial
application subsequent renewal
applications that Hillary bought and
paid for the dossier and it was never
verified and the law specifically says
to verify it don't we know that they
violated a law Mark Levin constitutional
scholar you know Sean Hannity let me
tell you something the judges on this
vice the court so far have gotten away
without being scrutinized you're a
federal judge forget about the FISA
Court a federal district judge appellate
court the Supreme Court and you know as
a matter of fact that you were misled
and I want everyone to listen to this
and you know as a matter of fact that
the information that was provided to you
or the information that wasn't provided
for full context led you to issue a
warrant to spy on an American citizen
under the idea that the American citizen
was an agent of Russia who was likely to
commit a crime and by the way that
citizen Carter page last time I checked
he hasn't been charged with anything if
you're a judge and we've had success of
judges in this FISA Court over a period
of one
here and you don't do something about it
Congress needs to look into this I do
not expect the Department of Justice to
investigate the Department of Justice I
just don't I don't expect the FBI to
investigate the FBI but I damn well
expect federal judges serving as FISA
Court judges to make sure that conduct
wasn't committed in front of them now
let me let me tell you something last
April landmark legal foundation filed
secretly with the FISA Court because we
don't have any staining nobody has
standing nobody really knows how this
works
and we said to the court hey court hey
judge guess what guess what just took
place in your courtroom here's what we
said you have the inherent jurisdiction
to order an investigation of the FBI to
get answers to this number one last
April have this court's order or orders
been used by intelligent and law
enforcement entities of the federal
government as a subterfuge to surveil
private citizens and at least one United
States Senator we were thinking of
sessions at the time for political
purposes number two did government
officials seek one or more national
security surveillance warrants from this
court as a pretext to conduct an
investigation for the purpose of
effecting an ongoing national
presidential campaign and subsequent
transition of an incoming president this
is last April number three when applying
to this court for one or more warrants
in this matter did the FBI inform this
court that it had apparently paid some
of the expenses of a former British spy
who prepared the dossier reportedly
relied on at Haller part in its
application to convince this court to
issue a warrant number four when
applying to this Court this is us to the
judge for one or more warrants in this
matter did the FBI inform this court
that the dossier it reportedly presented
in pursuit of one or more warrants had
originally been prepared by the former
British spy for a Washington research
firm conducting opposition research
against the Republican nominee for
president of the United States Donald J
Trump this is important landmark legal
foundation respectfully requests the
court the judge the FISA judge sitting
in bunk by herself that she should
direct the government to complete its
investigation and report its findings to
the court within 90 days the court
should also consider whether it's
appropriate to issue an order to all
relevant federal law enforcement and
intelligence agencies to show cause as
to why they should not be held in
contempt for failing to protect the
secrecy of classified information
obtained pursuant to the court order now
do you know what the judge said in
response to us the FISA Court judge I
want you to listen to this April 25 2017
this is rosemary Collier the presiding
judge keep in mind the judges on the
FISA Court are picked by the Chief
Justice of the Supreme Court these are
district court judges for the most part
so their existing federal court judges
she wrote in this little order the court
has received a pleading titled motion
for leave to appear as amicus curiae oh
no no no not slam R on April 21 that
five days later she says although
presented as a request to appear there's
no matter pending before the court with
respect to which such an appearance
would be proper now listen to me this
warrant was extended three times that
matter was still appearing before this
court that's number one number two the
court has ongoing jurisdiction to
supervise the conduct of attorneys the
FBI the Justice Department before the
court contempt may reach backwards even
after a case has been concluded in other
words this Feist a judge and quite
frankly was misdirecting when she said
the matters not before us anymore when
it was still before them and this court
like any federal court still has the
power to reach back and hold people
accountable she did nothing she did not
call in the FBI as far as we know she
did not call in the Justice Department
she did not answer for answers she did
not ask for an investigation she didn't
call the contempt hearing nothing you
know what that tells me something smells
like a rat which means that me ask you
this yeah yeah this is all great
information mark this is how I see this
remember the Grassley Graham memo huge
news they said the bulk of the FISA
application consisted of what we now
know to be unverified information fusion
GPS co-founder Glenn Simpson never
verified it the FBI never verified at
the deputy FBI director Andrew McCabe
literally said no dossier not even an
application you're right it's renewed
every 90 days so if you have an
opposition party candidate using
unverified Russian lies in the lead up
and then post election to undermine a
president and not at what we know as of
now is none of it is true is this based
on your knowledge of history at least
the biggest abuse of power and
corruption in your lifetime because well
yeah this is Watergate are you kidding
this is water sometimes a thousand to me
when you and I spoke way back in March
of last year and we laid this out we
recall kook's conspiracy theorists
almost everything we've said and we
didn't have a lot we were pulling it
together and I was focused specifically
on the FISA Court because the release
about the FISA Court but I want to
underscore something tonight Sean and it
is this these federal judges sitting on
this FISA Court act like they have no no
role in this baloney they were abused
the court was abused the court was
misled people should be held to account
they read the newspapers now they watch
television now we presented this judge
with the evidence and and filed it
lastly Congress needs to find out now
why these judges even today aren't
holding people accountable Comey said to
Trump in January 2017 to Trump our oh
it's salacious and it's unverified the
FISA application the first one was three
months earlier
he by his own words is admitting he
violated his doing Jarrett said earlier
many 6 loss these are felonies mark you
don't lie before a judge nor do you
prevent an institution I'm talking about
a court needs to protect itself agreed
any federal court in America if somebody
lies to a court omits material facts to
a court level the information is not
presented to the court a court has
misled federal judges every day they
hold people to account these judges in
the FISA Court have not let me just say
this quickly lasts more time to abolish
the FISA Court it's time to create a new
a counterintelligence related Court it
should not consist of existing federal
judges they should be confirmed not for
life terms for given terms the FBI and
the Justice Department where they go
into that court should not be alone
anymore there ought to be an office
within the federal government that's
there will ensure that civil liberties
are protected there are things we need
to do with this court is on your life
Liberty Levin Sunday nights 10:00
Eastern who's your guest this weekend we
have a full hour with chairman Nunez
only go over everything soup to nuts and
it's going to be absolutely loveless i
hope everybody watches I love Walter
Williams this past weekend great opening
show thank in the ratings awesome job
alright great one good to see you thank
you